what does it mean to be a multi-chain
solution we understand that means use
ethereum and solana but what does it
practically mean and what's the benefit
of being multi-chain
so
um
it's it's that uh you're thinking of the
i think these things are back-end
technologies and
they're not the web client there's it's
not like a a single thing with 3 000 or
i mean 3 billion users that all of the
same virtual machine
running locally so these are back-end
systems
and with back-ends you can pick and
choose whatever you need for whatever
solution you want and the thing that
really glues all this stuff together is
the cryptography
i can have cryptographic proofs that i
own something in ethereum i can move
that stuff over to solana through a
bridge and vice versa all this can be
automated through cryptography and the
users
shouldn't really care at the end of the
day
where this information is synchronized
or or managed
and so you can kind of pick the system
that you want for the use case that you
care about
and that that's kind of how i think of
the multi-chain world is that
this this stuff is complicated just like
a database there's pareto efficient
trade-offs
um and when you end up with pareto
efficient trade-offs somebody's going to
maximize one aspect of it and somebody
else is going to do something maximize
another so solana picked a very clear
different proto-efficient spot than
ethereum or ethereum 2 or bitcoin or any
you know any of the even competitors
like near avalanche et cetera which is
speed and low transaction cost
it is so that is a side effect to the
pareto efficient spot we picked we
picked um
a single shard so a single network that
fully replicates information as fast as
possible
so this this again speaks to my 12 years
of qualcomm
what how i look at this as a
uncensorable broadcast radio how do i
make sure that when you transmit a bit
it's propagated everywhere around the
world as fast as possible and that's
guaranteed
what is that going to look like if the
adoption right now you have
how many
parties and how many transactions
occurring that are real transactions a
day are we talking about billions
millions uh like 40 million a day but a
lot of that is coming from
like a central limit order book called
serum so market makers
all they do is some cancel orders cancel
cancel the sword
so let's say if the network went a
thousand x and all of a sudden you know
we're not 40 million
you know you're at
400 billion and then 4 trillion
what would the infrastructure need to be
in terms of the the storage the
bandwidth et cetera and you know because
that's eventually where this is heading
is that these things are going to hit
scale
would that look like you know the
footprint of google would it look like
the footprint of facebook's data centers
or would it looks like something
different so 1000x and humans
1000x in transactions maybe to start you
know or well so the thing is like
twitter right let's say we went from our
current humans you know which is maybe a
million like multi-active humans maybe
half a million
um to twitter's 200 million monthly
active users
we're going from
you know like 30 transactions per second
that are human to 5000 that's not a big
deal but the interest the read
infrastructure to support structuring
all this data and displaying to them
that's going to have the same footprint
as twitter there's no magic there but
the chain itself like the piece that
we're working on
that is scalable today to
that level easily
what what happened on september 17th i
know
you guys had a really rough day there
was a blackout for i don't know uh 12 17
hours 17 hours 17 hour block don't want
to bring up any ptsd i know this was
just two weeks ago you probably didn't
sleep but um you know this was a
you know like this is what happens when
you get popular we all remember at the
early days of twitter the foul whale it
was like yeah you know an existential
crisis here why did you go down what did
you learn from it and how do you prevent
that in the future so
this was really not the first time we
went down was kind of the first public
one the first time people noticed
because
nobody
so so the thing is that like what what
is decentralization
it's to say it's in my mind i think of
everything objectively it's the cost to
destroy every copy of the state
so
if the network goes down what it means
is that it stopped confirming confirming
blocks
but the ledger and the state is still
there
so there's multiple reasons why i could
stop confirming blocks uh everywhere
from like every government in the world
orders their telecoms to start dropping
your data and your kind of host
to major aws went down and for some
reason you had more than a third of the
stake in aws and no longer you can no
longer get to super majority a lot of
networks are susceptible to this or in
our case there was um
a radium launch for a product an idea
kind of think of it like a binance
exchange launch or something like this
and they're already bots optimized to
try to snipe orders
and
they got pretty good at their
optimizations and they flooded the
network with about 400 000 at peak
requests to make a transaction not
actual transactions and blocks but they
basically flooded it until
the network
could not handle that load and started
running out of memory got it but so that
would be like a denial of service attack
or a memory overflow kind of attack
which
has been solved in the dns space you
know uh through dyn and cloudflare and
others so i assume you figured out some
way to if
i don't know i say a bad actor but you
know if um somebody does something
outrageous
is it more resilient to the outrageous
moments like this where yeah
quality of service is not a it's not
like computer science problem it's just
a pain in the ass problem and you know
we test for this we flip the network all
the time there's just a couple corner
cases so when i get blamed that code it
was me who wrote it two years ago
where i had a couple unbounded queues
that were growing
so can only can only get played myself
but this is part of why we still want to
call it main beta is that we have
extremely high confidence in safety
right you only need one of these
replicas to survive one of these
replicas to be valid and the network is
already
as censorshippers like decentralized
from that physical perspective in my
mind as ethereum 2 or ethereum
um there isn't that significant
difference between a thousand replicas
and 5000 on ethereum btc like we're at
that
we're like a few a few more like you
know um
jumps behind but we're basically pretty
pretty much there but liveness and like
resilience to arbitrary attack vectors
while
guaranteeing low cost luffy
it to all the actual users
that's a um
probably will take a couple iterations
and probably will take
some iterations from
now till we get to 100 million users
right and then from 100 million users to
a billion
don't you wish you could hire a ringer
to help scale out your marketing team i
know you do well with marketer hire you
can and you can do it right now
marketer hire gives you access to
expert freelancers on demand with no
long-term contracts and no risk you can
hire experienced specialists across the
most valuable marketing disciplines from
paid social and search to growth seo
content and even get a fractional cmo if
you don't need a full-time one maybe a
fractional one would work great for you
again
no long-term contracts you can cancel at
any time and if it's your first time
working with freelance talent you'll
start with a no risk trial only hire
what you need and stay on budget with
hourly part-time full-time arrangements
every freelancer on market or hire goes
through a rigorous vetting process with
industry experts freelancers from market
or hire have been hired at over 1500
companies including top brands like
netflix all birds and lambda school
you're going to get 500 off your first
hire at marketerhire.com
twist again marketer
r e dot m-a-r-k-e-t-e-r-h-i-r-e-com
slash twist marketerhire.com slash twist
get that 500 right now and you'll also
get a free consultation on who to hire
based on your needs and your goals again
500 right now marketer hire dot com
slash twist